can you share three tangible takeaways
that people can use right away
like we said I want to go back to worthy
arrival that is the easy
one of all the infinite minded practices
to implement which is the other leaders
sometimes in your own team the other
people in your own team other companies
that make you slightly uncomfortable or
slightly angry when their name comes up
you know what is their strength what is
something they do that highlights a
weakness that you can focus on that
one's really easy and tangible uh to do
um I think other things is is start a
book club you know a lot of companies
tell me they can't afford or they don't
have time to implement leadership
training and I always say nonsense you
can afford to start a book club you know
pick a book that you want to read ask
you know make don't make it mandatory
make it voluntary that every Friday
we're going to review a chapter or two
and talk about it over lunch or whatever
um and that's called leadership training
and you can pick books that highlight
skills that you want to teach whether
it's purpose or whether it's listening
or whether whatever it is but please
please please start some sort of
leadership training and the third one is
take yourself on which is try to be the
leader you wish you had you know we
can't ask our people to do things if
we're not willing to do them ourselves
lead by example